James Cameron was one of the other
really amazing like I went to the
private screening of Avatar Wow when he
was right before he was coming out in
theaters at his my friend won a like
what auction there was an auction where
he got tickets to a private screening
right James Cameron's personal theater
at his at light storm
and so I go there with my buddy
and he's there and he does and it's only
like you know 15 maybe 20 people just
like a very intimate audience wow and he
goes he enters the films afterwards I'll
do a little q a you know no problem so
he comes in after the film and he says
like hey
and he's like answering questions and I
was like all these people are licking
his butt they're just ask they're not
even asking questions they're just
saying oh it's amazing the what you're
doing with this phone was like I'm gonna
ask him a real question like a geek so I
asked him about like I was like so I
heard about this really involved process
that you did with the motion capture
sensors for the face to capture the
facial movements I was like you want to
talk about that or exactly how did you
exactly do that and he looked at me and
he's like oh there's a great question
and then he pauses like you're John
Eater aren't you I was like oh my gosh
and so that was a huge wow like he was
like saying oh yeah me and my family
were fans
um that was that was a Starstruck mom
for sure